my sea shanties from tick tock got my
rental deal and this is that story
my name is nathan evans i'm from a small
place
just outside glasgow and scotland it's
called airdrie
it's not like exciting there's not much
to talk about one of the best things in
here is the train that takes you out
it all started back in january 2020. i
was a postman and i was just going about
my day-to-day job
i started my job about eight o'clock in
the morning i was finished for about
three o'clock in the afternoon
which meant i had all day after that and
all night
to thinking new ideas for songs thinking
new tech talk ideas
i've been singing since i was six years
old i don't think there's been a minute
where i don't think about music i'm not
singing i'm not playing guitar
so my views from tiktok when i first
started
i was getting maybe a couple of hundred
and it was slow for
for a while then in july someone decided
to leave a comment saying
could you sing a sea shiny called leave
her johnny i think you would be really
good at it
so i went away i've done some research
the purpose of sea shanties back
when they were signed was uh they were
sang on sailing ships and
in wailing ships and they were used to
keep the sails morale high
to keep them all happy to get them all
joining in if they were
hoisting sales or whatever they were
doing it was to keep them in time i
don't do well on boats
i get seasick so i went and i listened
to a whole load and see shanties
and i came back and uploaded the video
and the reception was amazing
[Music]
comments started coming in could you do
the drunken sailor could you do
the scotsman could you do the whaler man
and so i get ready to do the whaler man
on the 27th of december
and it blew up the once was a ship that
put to see
the name of the ship was a bully of tea
the winds blew
up her bird up down below my billy boy's
blow
the jewetts are probably one of my
favorite parts
of the whole process one person joins in
two people joins in
and then but before you know it there's
15 people all on this one video there's
somebody playing a violin there's
somebody
playing a harp and it's just all
together it's it's amazing
it was about three days later when when
i surpassed like a million viewers and
there was emails coming in about radio
show interviews and
tv shows managers there was booting
agents
so i spoke to a few people insulted a
lawyer and a manager
once i got the insulted 220 kid and
valentine they had then went and made
the remix
and radio stations loved it and that is
then when record labels started to get
in touch
now it's sitting at one and two and the
uk charts
the original and then the remix is
sitting there there is a music video in
the box and you'll hopefully get to see
that in the next couple of weeks
you'll hopefully hear a couple of
singles um in the coming months
and an album but in the year so keep
your eyes peeled
[Music]
you